cerca de 156 millones de personas fueron
llamadas a votar en el segundo país más
poblado de América donde viven casi 215
millones de habitantes Brasil es el
estado con mayor número de católicos del
mundo sin embargo los fieles
evangelistas ganan peso político al
representar ya un tercio de la población
Hace cuatro años siete de cada diez
evangélicos apoyaron al actual
presidente Yahir bolsonaro a pesar de
que según los datos de 2020 de la cepal
un 18% de la población vive en la
pobreza y que es uno de los 20 países
más desiguales del mundo según el índice
de Ginny de 2021 Brasil también es
potencia económica global según el Banco
Mundial el pib brasileño aumentó el 4,6%
en 2021 con una proyección de
crecimiento de 1,5% para 2022 el país es
la mayor economía regional y la décima
del planeta según el fondo monetario
internacional un modelo en los servicios
el sector financiero y el comercio de
productos y recursos naturales como la
soya la madera la carne los minerales y
los hidrocarburos de hecho la
explotación de la minería la agricultura
y la ganadería están a la raíz de la
deforestación de la amazonía que ha
alcanzado niveles de Récord bajo la
presidencia de Jair bolsonaro una
tendencia que ha suscitado preocupación
global dado que las fronteras de Brasil
el quinto país más grande del mundo
contienen más del 60% de la selva
amazónica por eso en los últimos años
han surgido propuestas para acordar un
nuevo estatuto de protección
internacional al pulmón del mundo para
que su preservación no quede a la Merced
de ideologías negacionistas del cambio
climático como la del presidente de
turno
que busca su reelección en estos
comicios una contienda marcada por la
atención en la disputa contra el
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
según el foro brasileño de seguridad
pública siete de cada 10 brasileños
tienen miedo a ser agredidos físicamente
por expresar su opinión política en una
campaña manchada de violencia hasta el
punto de suscitar la preocupación de
Naciones Unidas que ha pedido a las
autoridades de Brasil el desarrollo
Pacífico de los comicios y el respeto de
las instituciones electorales después de
que el mandatario Yair bolsonaro
alimentar a reiteradamente dudas
infundadas sobre la fiabilidad del
sistema de Voto electrónico que rige en
el país desde 1996 pesa la incertidumbre
de si el actual presidente aceptaría los
resultados si las urnas no le dan la
victoria